[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
dead is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today he is a number one
best-selling author he's also the host
of the fastest growing podcast in the
ramsey network called the dr john
deloney show where people call in with
mental health questions relationship
questions we'll take those today as we
always do and we'll also take questions
about your job your career and oh even
your money andrew is going to start off
this hour in milwaukee hey andrew what's
up
hi dave thank you for uh taking my call
pleasure speaking with you you too sir
how can we help
so my question is
i'm in the middle of my baby step two
i'm hitting it with gazelle intensity
however i'm also
about one and a half years into my
relationship both of us are
we know we want to get married it's
going to happen this year my question is
essentially how much should i be
budgeting for the engagement ring
and
when do i buy the ring is it my next
paycheck all that goes to the ring or is
that a sinking fund sometime within this
year the question about how much to
budget
i'm basically asking because i know you
typically say one month pay
my
one month pay is very different compared
to base compared to what i'm making
right now in gazelle intensity um
getting all the overtime that i am
getting
okay well congratulations how old are
you
i just turned 26 two days ago
awesomeness man well this is fun what a
great time for you okay so your range
of one month's pay plus base plus hustle
is what
what's the bottom end of this idea and
the top end of this idea
so yearly gross um base is 80. okay
right now gazelle intensity i'm taking
home 3 500 every two weeks paycheck
okay all right all right so 80 to 120
okay correct and so um what does she
make
she currently um
is between 40 to 50. what's she doing
she's in between jobs but that's
she was a director for a music program
now she's looking to transition to
potentially hr so she'll either one of
you grow up wealthy
uh no okay all right
well because there's a whole pl there's
a whole thing a whole lot of things that
go into this um the idea of one month is
to give folks a guideline because the
jewelry store the retail jewelry store
people will tell you three months but
that's a crock you don't need to spend
that much
um number two you know what i was trying
to ascertain is expectations based on
her income how she was brought up those
kinds of things
and so and there's all these stories and
everything about rings and everything
else it's a fun time you're in for sure
and i want you guys to have fun with the
whole process and so we don't want the
ring to be
the center of the attention because you
went nuts on one side and we don't want
it to be the center of the attention
because you didn't spend enough on it
either on the other side right so that's
that's kind of the balance i'm looking
for just as a old grandpa here um so if
i'm in your shoes you know probably the
five thousand dollar range is probably
going to be fine that'll be a buy pretty
dadgum nice ring
i will tell you that diamonds having
bought quite a few of them over the
years
um
uh because the one i bought when i
started i had to upgrade a couple times
since but um
anyway the uh
they are completely worthless
and don't let anybody talk to you about
an investment the investment aspect of
them is a freaking joke the only
investment is into your relationship
and how she feels
okay
but uh i've got
i don't know i don't even want to say
how much tied up in diamonds and i have
no expectation that they're going up in
value
because they generally don't it's just a
croc okay so don't get all caught up in
that the second thing about diamonds you
need to know is they're marked up
as much as anything we buy
furniture and diamonds double
they're double
okay so when you walk into the mall
jewelry store it's double what you can
get it from a diamond broker for
and so start doing some research and
learning because you can get
double for bang bang for your buck and
you need to learn a little bit about the
purchase process
uh the carrot the cut the clarity uh
those kinds of things and what makes a
good diamond but again don't get all
caught up in you know one flaw that the
naked eye can't see in the thing and so
it's a
it's a two instead of a one or whatever
and uh
because it's not going to matter
uh if anybody gets
that close to it they don't need to be
able to learn
it's fun to learn i i would just get
with uh somebody in your life that's
bought some in the past and or
if you can find a great diamond broker
in your area that will teach you a
little bit but don't get caught up in
the uh and shop around the last thing is
if you could really get somebody knows
how to put a glass on their eye the best
place to buy one's pawn shop
because it'll be it'll be a third
of what you'll find in the in the retail
and you might but you might pick you
might buy a piece of glass too and not
know what you're buying if you don't
get somebody who knows how to put a
glass on their eye and look at it with
you so i would be scared to do that if i
didn't know the pawn shop owner huh
if i don't know anyone like that a
broker that's a pretty safe bet yeah but
just but again you got to go in there
like you do anything else where you're
doing an investment purchase and you
you're going in with finding somebody
with a heart of a teacher to teach you
about it okay okay and and the last
thing is this you're not going to mess
this up
because there's absolutely zero research
between the correlation the size of the
rock and the success of the marriage
but there is a lot of research on
husbands who
take a knee and they propose and then
they followed up with and i got this at
a pawn shop
hey it depends on who you are and where
i got mine to punch up my wife would
have been so happy that's incredible but
yeah yeah other people wouldn't but
here's the thing there may be some
inverse relationship this as the rock is
too big the failing of the marriage is
predicted but because it seems to be
we're concentrating on the wrong things
here which is the relationship versus
the rock so as she talked to you about
it like what she's looking for
yeah i mean she she's given me her
expectations which are i mean she's
aware of how important it is for me to
get out of baby step two so she's giving
me yeah but i i don't option you take a
month off and go do this and do it right
but no it's not a ten thousand dollar
purchase in my mind and it's not a one
thousand dollar purchase
okay so pause baby step two to build up
five thousand dollars based on what i'm
making and then buy it resume baby step
two that's what there you go and here's
the thing i i know a lot of guys that
will have this conversation with the
person that they're going to get engaged
to
and then the person tells them hey this
is what i would love this is kind of
what the kind of band i would like and
the guy goes rogue because he thinks oh
actually i'm going to get and so man if
she's honorable enough to tell you
then listen listen man this is this is
test number one for many many tests to
come over the years just listen i'll
just tell you i don't buy them anymore
at all unless sharon does the design
she does my wife does not do surprises
is she not happy with the surprise
because i'm always wrong right so
i just
that's what she's she's not she loves
surprises she doesn't like it other
ladies like it they like that they like
the you put time and effort into it and
so forth but i've made that mistake a
couple times and i'll never do it again
so no we don't buy anything shiny
without sharing
actually approving
being in on it so you could go that
route if you want to go really crazy
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
building wealth is a really hot topic
right now it's all over your social
media it's jamming up your email inbox
it's on the talk shows and podcasts the
late night news everyone's got an
opinion on how to get rich
quick
and how crypto or single stocks or zero
down real estate
gold
whatever is the way to do it oh and
throw in inflation for a big dose of
fear on top of your fomo right
so in january we had a huge sold out
event here in nashville called wealth
building live
and we talked about how to build wealth
real wealth it was incredible the energy
in the room was amazing and it's so
awesome that we want to do it again so
we're hitting the road we're going to
get out there we're going to meet you
guys in person that's right the building
wealth live
event will be on tour in cities across
the country this year
the first city on our tour is orlando so
get ready orlando join me rachel cruz
george campbell when building wealth
live comes to you may 19th also john
deloney and ken coleman will be along
with us we'll be doing some stuff with
them as well tickets start at just 25 or
you can get a four pack for only 60
bucks that way you can sign up and bring
your friends that's a good idea that's a
deal come on guys i mean seriously be
sure to sign up for one of these uh one
night special events and we'll give you
the real story on the quickest
fastest most
sure way
to build wealth ramsey solutions dot com
slash events to buy tickets now orlando
is
on sale now ready set go our question
today comes from blinds.com
find out for yourself why blinds.com is
the number one online retailer of custom
window coverings you get free samples
free shipping new promos all the time
you'll save even more use the promo code
ramsey and you'll have the best deal
today's question comes from james in
alabama james writes i'm in an
embarrassing situation i'm 36 years old
and i'm a hoarder
i have over 50 000 invested into video
games comics and toys
this is consuming the home that my
mother and i live in which is making her
unhappy
i have about 15 000 in debt and earn
about 35 grand a year i'm really
starting to wake up after watching your
show and i've been thinking about
selling 99 of my stuff and living a
simpler life
i just feel lost in the process and i
have trouble letting things go how can i
change my mindset about these things
i've collected
this tough
um
dave this is one of those challenges
that people start trying to solve the
the immediate pros the immediate problem
right in front of them
and you can do that but something that
is
going on in james life i'm gonna guess
is deep seated that he needs to go do
some hard work he's 36 still living at
home he's packed up stuff he's he's
running and hiding this is a person
who's very anxious
and has probably got some childhood
trauma that he's dealing with so when i
feel people get in this situation i just
can't break through i can't break i
can't break this person needs to go sit
down and she's awesome boarding is the
symptom not the problem correct right it
is usually
um a response almost always is actually
some sort of anxiousness or trauma
response yeah i've had some stuff go on
and i just start collecting and
collecting and collecting and i don't
want to let go because i might need it
it's preparatory and all of a sudden you
look up and you can't move in your home
right
and this guy's distinguished for me
because i i've got this friend
who might be a little bit ocd and uh
he's got collections of things i have a
collection of water skis i have a
collection of
wine i have a collection of guns i have
a collection of whatever right
and um those things are things i got
drawn into
and usually the community around them
and that they represent and or the
memory or something um and so i just
enjoyed the process and they and they
sometimes not all of them but some
things run their course like i i used to
buy a lot more guns than i buy now yeah
but i've kind of got the i'm kind of
full so i haven't bought in a bunch of
don't buy
anywhere near the volume i used to uh so
i kind of ran its course so to speak but
that's a what's the difference in a
collector and a hoarder
uh i would suggest a collector or
somebody like you said that has a good
community this is something you do this
is something you enjoy that thing that
you're buying doesn't own you right okay
and so i get a paycheck
i can't not go buy this thing okay it's
an addiction
and if i said if if sharon came to you
and said we have to sell some of these
guns your initial response is
i can't do that oh actually not an
intellectual argument not a not a well
why would we do that it's i can't part
with this and so you can look at
somebody's house who's a hoarder and say
throw it away
you're asking them to peel back layers
of security that they've walls that
they've built literally okay and so
this starts with man there's even even a
difference between someone who's a very
aggressive um
because i can remember like times i've
been in a zone like i i got on a hunt
for that thing yeah cause to complete
the collection you're a hunter yeah
and i enjoyed that part of it but that's
different than i can't live without it
spiritually and you also did it
differently when you had resources and
finances and when you didn't oh yeah
yeah it's a very very small percentage
of the world that's your net worth right
it's not like okay i'm feeling better
because i was kind of worried
well if you ever need to unload some of
your wine or guns or bourbon holler at
me and uh i know a guy but
so james here's the thing um i want you
to reach out to a friend reach out to a
pastor in your community that you trust
a counselor reach out to somebody and
say
i'm ready to get well and this is going
to be hard and you're gonna have some
stuff you have to deal with you're gonna
have to go back and revisit some stuff
that's going on in your life but the
fact that you're ready is so good man
it's hard to get people here it feels
like if you if he were to come up under
this
and start getting well the result would
be the release of it it can be that you
just started wouldn't be it wouldn't be
as much of a tearing right it feels like
right now there'd be a
ripping sound a tearing sound and when
that happens is what happens you'll find
somewhere else to plug this so you can
hire a crew to come clean your house out
throw everything away and that addiction
will just jump to something else yeah
right yeah the problem is still is still
under there that's right somewhere
that's right but good for you james yeah
and you know here's the other thing i've
i've bought real estate from people that
were hoarders yes and um
tremendous problem
uh
even getting inside to see the house on
the inside the shame yeah from our true
hoarders
the shame around it is unbelievable you
just pull called something that's
important a lot of people think i'm a
hoarder
and then you go to somebody's home who's
a true hoarder and you go oh it's trash
yeah i bought houses like that and we
had to you know entire dumpsters outside
after the you know maybe even the
hoarder had passed away and we started
from the estate and gone in and cleaned
it out it's amazing and it's
mind-blowing when you go in there so
anytime you're about identity change it
starts with looking in the mirror and
saying i'm worth more than this and
let's start the healing there but good
for you james i'm proud of you brother
yeah um very good stuff very good man
yeah that's very smart to recognize that
and here's the other thing he did really
good that i think is a sign for his
healing is he put numbers around this
and he started recognizing they were out
of balance because he put him in the
email he did two things that were i make
35 i got 50
and uh and i owe 15. yep i heard the
three numbers and i want to sell 99 of
this stuff
yeah so he did two things he put numbers
around it and he took full
responsibility yeah he didn't say i have
this because of the he said yeah this is
on me and i got to make some changes
where do i start yeah and this starts
with saying stuff out loud to somebody
else but still once he even though he's
that that's a really good first rung on
the ladder he's still got to get up
under it
otherwise it's going to just his parts
of his heart are going to leave
he needs to detach from the heart before
the stuff leaves that's right that's
exactly right that's a great way to put
that
wow this isn't a matter of just throwing
stuff away you know in america we've all
got just about everybody's got stuff
it's of some kind there's i get that
i'll be happy if i could just get that
card i'll be happy if i could buy
billions and billions of dollars that we
have in storage was a billion square
foot of storage space yeah i don't know
it's ridiculous yeah yeah we spend more
on storing stuff than most countries gdp
yeah bonkers stuff that we don't use
yeah we're the only country in the world
that when someone moves they have a box
labeled seldom used kitchen
items it's like yeah i've gotta
i i'll be happy when
i'll be happy i get that thing from
ronco that's the big difference the two
sets of knives can you be happy without
that gun could you be happy without that
car would it be cool and nice of course
it would
will i still be worth being loved if i
don't have that yes yeah i quit buying
cars for other people a long time ago
that's that's another thing's going
broke but i still got really nice cars
again i got really nice cars but they're
for me i love that just because i like
driving it and i don't really care
whether you like it or not because i
like it yeah that's a whole different
thing than i used to do in my 20s whole
different thing
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today here on the ramsay show in
the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage zach and becky are with
us hey guys how are you great how are
you better than i deserve where do you
guys live
fargo north dakota fargo north dakota
it's a bit of a haul to nashville just a
little bit whew did your driver fly we
flew
i guess i hope so oh my goodness how
cold is it there right now
i don't want to know
that is a great answer says the guy in
shorts in tennessee i like it all right
how much debt did you guys pay off 170
000. very good how long did this take
four and a half years or so wow
and your range of income during that
time 45 to 105. oh nice jump okay cool
what do y'all do for a living i stay at
home with the girls and zach flies
fly you're a pilot yeah yeah i do a
small cargo uh company fly ups right
under contract very cool a superhero
that's fantastic
yeah that's worth the cape yeah so the
uh 170 000 in debt was what
car and student loans whoa sally may got
a big chunk huh yeah yep unfortunately
flight school oh flight school ah there
it is all right well she still had to be
kicked out yes ugly woman didn't need
her own bedroom in your house all right
i like it way to go you guys how long
you been married five and a half years
okay so one year into marriage you
decide go gangbuster on this tell us
about what happened
um during our like marriage prep course
we um
had a financial um
teacher i guess during our like weekend
retreat thing whatever and it happened
to be one of zach's professors that he
looked up to so it was like we already
kind of know his
story and
yeah so he shared his story and we kind
of thought it was really cool and we
kind of dropped it after that for a
little bit and then so he kind of had a
ramsay story or whatever oh yeah he did
the whole thing and he recommended your
total money makeover book okay you did
none of it immediately correct yeah
right because we were still in school
you know there's not so much we can do
you know what we thought and what
student listens to the professor exactly
you know it takes like six months to
brew you know
okay so you're married yes a year in
what woke you up what was like oh god we
gotta do this um it was like a couple
months after we got married we read the
book together oh um and then
just started knocking them out the first
year we were pretty strong and then
um i was teaching at the time
we got pregnant we thought you can't do
this when you're pregnant you know so we
kind of laid back a little bit went
davish um we ended up moving to sioux
falls south dakota for
six months
i stopped teaching because i stayed at
home with um our oldest daughter abby
and zach started at this current job he
has now but like a
lower
salary yeah lower on the totem pole
um we moved back up to fargo because
there was a better opportunity with the
job
um now he's kind of like the head guy at
fargo so that's cool
bumped up our salary had another kid in
the midst um
and
just kept working on our salary yeah and
her brother met with some smartvestor
pros in iowa and we're like oh well we
should look into that too and so stop
the like davish and want gazelle intense
oh okay yeah finally figured it out so
babies and moves we turned the heat up
and down yeah yeah and finally turned
the heat up and knocked it out so then
after we met with tana our smartvestor
pro
she kind of kicked us in the pants and
had us set a goal and we actually
knocked that goal out of the water all
right there we go
game on hey i like it you got there yeah
yeah you got there i like it it's a good
and that's a real story that's not
somebody that's too fake to be believed
y'all really did this yeah the last like
year we paid um over a hundred thousand
it was a year and a half i guess over a
hundred thousand so so the vast majority
of it just lately yeah yeah wow so i've
met with a lot of students over the
years and they look at a number this
high
and they kind of just quit yeah like
that number's high and you all chipped
away at it for three years how did you
keep from getting frustrated and just
killing each other
um i mean we were kind of very big just
killing him it was just yeah
yeah
no one would have ever found him right
yeah right right right
um but yeah it was just kind of you know
we wanted to see the loan number go down
and our money in our pocket go up right
change the family tree for a girl so
give them something to look forward to
instead of just a mountain of debt um so
that was kind of the big motivating
factor and we just wanted to live our
lives instead of paying out to the banks
so have you had that moment where you've
paid off everything and your check is
deposited and you get to keep all that
yeah
so now it's going towards our house well
we had finished our six month emergency
fund so now it's just
saving for a house that we don't have
right now so it's just
there's a lot like shifting the
intensity to yeah getting rid of our
well now to get something you want
instead of getting rid of something you
hate right right that's more fun yeah it
is yeah yeah good for you guys well done
i'm proud of you what do you tell people
the key to getting out of details
um stick to a budget um
we didn't have beans and rice
necessarily but off-brand mac and cheese
is really good yeah yeah i'm with you
all right
yeah second of the budget you know just
keeping an eye on all the little
purchases and right the little adds up
yep the little things make a big
difference um
we sold a lot of stuff on like facebook
marketplace um raising our incomes acted
doordash for a while
so any little thing helps
so what do you tell people the key okay
at the 18 month mark you met with
smartvestor pro you set a goal and
that's when the intensity kicked in yeah
and you never let up during that 18
months and did most of the work during
that time right yes what do you tell
people that key was
um
what was it that all of a sudden went
okay fire on yeah we're doing this i
think we're just tired of like being the
davish and like it's not really going
away very fast you know we just really
need to keep up with the intensity um i
think it was tauna that had suggested
like writing down our
um
dead snowball and putting it on the
fridge so you see it all the time and
that didn't really affect him so much
but it was like in my face all day long
since i stayed home with the girls
um so and then just having all sorts of
like charts and stuff that you can color
in or whatever it was helpful for me
yeah anything visual yes it's helpful
yeah visual's very motivating is it true
that your kids will survive if they
don't have everything that they wish
yeah you know they don't agree with that
you know at the time but you know you
have to learn how to say no when you're
at the grocery store and they want you
know all the fancy cereals that are
garbage for you anyway so it's actually
gotten to the point we're gonna go out
to eat one night and our older daughter
she's like well we can't go out to eat
we have to save for buying a house yeah
so we were like well we have gift cards
for that because we have gift cards from
christmas you know so that's okay put
the box back now we're rationalizing to
the six-year-old yeah we have cereal out
of the bag mommy yeah way to go and
she's three and a half and she's like we
can't have chick-fil-a we don't have
money for that we have to save for a
house oh good oh perfect that's so
perfect oh that's good she's gonna be
listening to my show in a few years
[Laughter]
way to go you guys we're very proud of
you very impressive who are your biggest
cheerleaders outside the two of you
um our girls i guess if it's outside the
two of us yeah and her brother was a
pretty big supporter too what about the
professor that he just
and him and yeah we just didn't see him
as often since we left grand forks after
that oh actually yeah okay does he know
you did all this now yes he's watching
right now i think so yeah what's his
name uh dan my lot all right we'll give
him a shout out very good thanks dan all
right
now this is a life that was changed
right here well done i love it guys we
got a copy of baby steps millionaires
for you that's the next chapter in your
story how ordinary people build
extraordinary wealth how you can too
it's the number one best seller and our
gift to you know the number one
bestseller total money makeover gonna
give you one of those and you can give
it away to somebody and disturb them the
way uh the way prof did for you that'll
be good stuff so well done you two very
well done zach and becky fargo north
dakota 170
000 paid off in four and a half years
most of it in the last 18 months making
45 to 105. count it down let's hear a
debt-free scream
three two one
[Applause]
yeah
what a great cup off
175 thousand dollar is a tall now that's
a clear whole mountain yeah it's a big
mountain to climb and most of it's
student loans i mean and that's that
that's the big topic out there that it
can't be done it can't be done yes it
can okay yes it can zac and becky from
fargo north dakota just did a mic drop
yes it can be done they did it and uh
they're walking social proof that you
can too
so you can do it when you're pregnant
you could do it with your a kid you can
do it while you're renting you can do it
when you're trading jobs you can do it
you can do it you can do it well it's
just a matter it has to be front and i
like the front and center thing with the
visual yeah that just gets in your face
messes with you
constantly reminding you it's very very
good very good stuff
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsay personality is my
co-host today
drake is with us in kansas city hi drake
welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how's it going better than i
deserve what's up
well
pretty much i
was lucky enough to live with the best
dad
anybody could ever ask for
best friend growing up all that long
story short he passed away a few years
ago and
left me a pretty good chunk
of money
um it's in a trust fund right now i
won't see any of it until i'm 25 years
old
i'm a college student right now i'm 22
so i've got about three years left to go
uh basically i i have a few ideas of
kind of what i should do and how i
should save it investments like real
estate and stuff like that down the road
um but pretty much i just wanted to see
kind of if you were me
or if you were in my shoes what were
what would be some things you would do
with a big chunk like this how much is
it
um i've got about
550 000 in a 401k
and then about 438 in calf
and i've got about
18 18 000 in my own right now that i
have access to okay
and you're 22 how old was he
uh he was
53 when he passed away wow what happened
yeah um
sadly it was a uh
terminal disease um lou gehrig's disease
so it was yeah
i'm sorry uh pretty rough yeah i'm sorry
sorry for what you've been through yeah
okay i appreciate that but uh yeah a
couple of things i mean more than
anything you just need some principles
to guide you
okay instead of specific tactics let me
give you some principles
number one principle go slow
there's no reason to be fast
number two don't put money in anything
you don't understand
just because somebody says it they know
this or they know that or you read an
article on the internet god help you
don't do that
um or because even dave ramsey said to
do it don't do it you don't put money in
something unless you understand it
if you understand it you can learn from
people like me
to where you understand it then you can
go forward but just because it's shiny
and flashy and cool and the cool kids
are all doing it does not mean you put
money in it as a matter of fact that
usually means you don't
um the other thing you can remember is
this having studied wealthy people for
the past 30 years i find that their
investing strategies are by and large
very boring
they're not super uber sophisticated
they don't do uh you know limited family
partnership double back flips there's no
weird stuff
all these things you hear
that the rich have secrets they really
don't
they go slow they know what they put
money in they understand it they don't
put money in something unless they
understand it and therefore they don't
lose it and it generally makes some
money but they're not trying to hit the
home run every time they're just trying
to make money on their money
just steady right and so uh it doesn't
matter what you put money in as long as
you understand it and you know you know
what it is and you do it so um
you know so i know a lot about real
estate i grew up in the real estate
business my parents were in the business
when i was a kid i got my license when i
turned 18. i'm very very comfortable
with real estate consequently i have a
bunch of it
okay right but someone who's scared to
death and has never done it or never
dealt with a tenant you would want to go
super super slow
test it a little bit test it a little
bit test it a little bit it's second
nature for me though
okay
same thing with mutual funds i i really
do not have any investments personally
except mutual funds and real estate
that's all i have okay because i got
really comfortable with it doesn't have
to be sexy or cool if the cool kids
don't like it i don't really care i'm
not investing for them
right you know hey ramsay doesn't
understand dave ramsey's got several
hundred million dollars dave ramsey
understands something okay all right so
um you know that that's just you know
that that's but that's what i find when
i talk to
you know the uh you know you're the
person you're talking to if they've got
a little gray hair it's probably a good
idea
uh because i i was young and rich and
lost everything i didn't want his
opinion when i started surveying people
about how money works because he was an
idiot he lost everything that's me i'm
talking about so
but i did i did high leverage get rich
quick real estate and it bit me in the
butt
because i've violated a lot of common
sense rules so all of that to say do
that the last thing i'll tell you is
this in the multitude of council there
is safety
and so if i were a 25 year old
millionaire sudden sudden millionaire
i would uh build a board of directors
for my life not that tells me what to do
a board of advisors i'd have a high
quality insurance broker an estate
planner
a tax attorney
an investment broker
all that i can call and speak to
about taxes about insurance about real
estate a good real estate person i'd
have a little collection of people that
i i you don't necessarily have to call
them all together at any time but they
need to um they're there to advise you
with the heart of a teacher they're not
there to tell you what to do
they're not there to be arrogant and act
like they have their god's gift to
whatever
um
the if you get if you sense that
arrogance run from them uh but get some
teachers in your corner because you have
to go slow and you have to invest only
in things you don't understand
the one that you do understand the one
thing i'd add dave is i didn't
understand this until
i got older and started having
money don't don't use this money to
leverage
this money to go get some more yeah
the number of folks who said hey you
want to put 10 in on this or 25 in on
this or hey we're all going in to buy
this apartment you want to put 15 on
this
they they like me as a friend but what
they really want is my money to make
their picture of what they want to do
come true and it's easy to take that
money and think you can parse it out and
make a bunch of people happy and make a
bunch of money ever you end up spreading
it all out and you end up wait you can
lose that money quick yeah right i the
only ship on sale is a partnership i'm
not in any partnerships
i own it
or i'm not in it it's okay and that
means i got lots of friends that do all
kinds of stuff like that but i don't i
don't do it i'm just my life is low
drama
very low drama right it's just downright
boring
you know and i kind of like it i like it
that way that's right that's it wasn't
intentional max is in canada hey max
let me try again
there he is max is in canada what's up
max
hi how are you doing sir great how can
we help
great i'm going to try and be as
straight and transformative as i
possibly can i'll just give you a little
overview first right now i'm just
finishing up my last year of university
i'm graduating this may
i have enough funds to be able to pay
off my student loans which i've done as
well as 10 000 for my initial starting
emergency fund i guess for six months
where'd it go
um yeah the one thing i wanted to throw
into is i read ken's proximity principle
book this summer and it was an absolute
game changer so if there's any other
university students watching or anything
i'd highly recommend that book
my question for you today is i've been
able to land a full-time job that i'm
going to be starting this summer after
graduation
the company currently does not offer
anything in terms of retirement matching
and i'm kind of looking at my different
retirement offer options i know that you
recommend about 15
so i'm looking here in canada we have a
tfsa which is similar to a roth ira
but that's not a traditional retirement
account how this one works is i can put
in 6 000 per year and that money grows
tax-free i'm wondering when it comes to
retirement would it make more sense to
max that out first before putting money
into a traditional retirement account
we tell folks stateside to do roth
before they do traditional because it
grows tax-free
and if i'm understanding what you just
presented to me i'm not an expert on
canadian retirement plans okay but if i
understand what you just said this is
more of a roth it's 6 000 and it grows
tax-free the traditional grows
after tax and i mean it's an it's a
pre-tax investment and it grows with
taxation on the whole account correct
yes sir okay so it's just like our plan
state side the way you described it it's
a traditional versus a roth so we always
tell people do a roth first
because the tax-free growth is going to
be a
it's going to amount to a whole lot more
than than the
obviously the after-tax effect of the
other other account so pretty simple
sounds like you really got this on the
run max way to go and all the parents
out there with little kids i want you to
imagine
15 20 years from now
your kids in the last semester of
college
do you want him to have a conversation
like he just had how do i start
investing my money after i've got my
emergency fund or do you want them to be
making a phone call saying how do i pay
all the student loan stuff off and that
starts when your kids are really young
with some decisions you make
conversations you have as parents
have those conversations have a plan
there we go nicely done that puts this
hour of the ramsey show in the box
[Music]
hey it's john delony co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where dad
is dumb cash is king and the paid off
home mortgage has taken the place of the
bmw as the status symbol of choice i'm
dave ramsey your host dr john dolone
ramsey personality is my co-host today
as we answer your questions about your
life
your money your mental health your
relationships your job your career
all of it's on the line right here at
the ramsey show thank you for joining us
logan is going to start off this hour in
dayton ohio hey logan what's up
hey david john how you all doing better
than we deserve how can we help
all right going to be on the show i'll
get uh right to it um so i've been
watching your youtube videos online for
about two weeks now
kind of a really strange way to end up
finding it but i'm very thankful that i
did
my parents taught me a lot about
finances growing up so thankfully uh
where i'm at in life i'm actually on
baby step six
i'm 24 years old i have a mortgage now
uh with my house in dayton ohio and i
had a question regarding it um so
i again i started watching two weeks ago
uh so i'll let you know some of the
decisions i made not quite in line
but i got a house in november on a
30-year va mortgage
um so right now i have it financed for
161 thousand dollars
i have my emergency savings all up
everything like that's good
but i have 35 000
that is in uh mutual funds that my
parents set up for me for college i'm in
the military so our college is paid for
thankfully um so trying to find out what
i want to do with that i'm looking at
being here between three and five years
and dayton um so in talking with my
parents a little bit of confusion and
trying to figure out what will be the
best option uh is it to put that money
you know onto the principal and just try
to try to knock that down as quick as
possible or to keep it in like a mutual
funds because it is it is growing pretty
decently in there
[Music]
well thank you for your service
oh absolutely my my pleasure what do you
do in the military
uh the air force uh i work uh easiest
way to describe would be like military
police so base security got you okay
cool good for you
very nice thank you well um
our normal process is we try to
determine what the shortest distance
between where you are right now
and wealthy is
what's the shortest distance
okay
and having studied wealthy people and
people that built wealth for 30 years
and lots of data on the subject
we have found that the first one to five
million dollars in net worth that people
get
generally comes from two areas um
the uh
the the wonderful built up retirement
plan in your case the tsp
um and uh and a paid for house
those are the two things that we talk to
the typical millionaire with their first
one to five million dollars of net worth
is usually their paid for home and their
retirement accounts
their roth iras and their 401ks and that
kind of stuff and that's where it is and
so
you can try to get there other ways but
we find very few people that do
i i don't i you know the number of
millionaires that we talked to when we
studied 10 000 of them that said i
borrowed money on my house and put it
into the stock market because the stock
market was doing really good and that
made me a millionaire
was really close to zero hardly any of
them did
uh everybody talks about that
and a lot of uh
bad financial advisors recommend that
but it's in real practice actually
finding wealthy people who really did it
there's not many of them
and so that's what i go with i say let's
get the house paid off and let's build
up your retirement accounts now you're
going to be moving
but the good news about paying that 35
000 down on your principal is when you
sell your house they're going to give
you a check for the equity it's not like
you spent the money
you just moved it over onto the house
your net worth doesn't change
right okay so yeah that way you know
whenever i do move you know that's just
going towards
yeah be sure be sure you sell the house
when you leave don't have long distance
landlording everywhere you
get stationed you end up with a house
and a rental property and you end up
with 17 rental properties in 17 places
you were stationed over the last 30
years or something in the military
career but
don't do that that's a disaster um but
so sell it when you leave and then you
may even rent depending on how far how
long you're going to be in the next
place
but um just just again don't go with
what they said and i heard they're the
worst financial planners on the planet
everybody's got a dead gum opinion
they're the worst mental health
practitioners they're worth marriage
counselors the worst pet owners it's
like you know the current version of
going to the old old-school barber shop
like floyd's on maybe rfd right you sit
around a bunch of old men and they're
all going to tell you how to do
something because they don't know how to
do yep and the current version of that's
google in it except that that
accepted that barbershop had some common
sense well they they
looked at the guy down the way and said
you're an idiot you don't tell that boy
that and then they would say no you
don't there was you could hear it back
and forth google tells you exactly what
you want to hear yeah and you know if
you're if you get sick the last thing
you need to do is google it
because it will scare you because you're
dead
you're dying of whatever it is you're
dead and there's also a natural uh
homeopathic answer for whatever you've
got essential oils
and essential oils death essential oils
special homeopathic witch doctors yeah i
mean there's every it's something
everywhere dave the letters we're going
to get on by the essential oils people
really care i mean it's just it's okay
if you want to do those things they're
going to they're gonna poke pins in a
doll but they uh but but you know you're
gonna get whatever you want to do but
but the thing is yeah so that that's it
they said not heard don't you know when
broke people are giving you financial
advice run power did it's a good rule
right there run david's in san antonio
hi david welcome to the ramsey show
hey dave how are you doing great man
what's up
hey uh my wife and i are in a bit of a
conundrum we don't know what to do and
we're hoping for some guidance
we seven years ago purchased our dream
home and built it and then life happened
and i got a job across town and we got
another home
and we didn't sell the dream home
we continue to rent it it's been a
rental for about four years now
um
our primary home we owe 370 on
and our rental home
we owe 320
and our tenant has been in that house
for two years
is requesting to purchase it for
fair market value we got a cma done and
she's willing to give us that market the
cma price how much and also willing to
not use military
uh 480.
okay she got 100 grand coming your way
uh after taxes and everything our tax
guy said we'd looking about 130.
okay
all right good and the deal is
the wife wants to sell and put a 120 or
130 down on the house our primary home
and recast the loan and save some money
i
am looking at wanting to continue
running it and hoping i can sell it for
200 or 250 or 300 grams coffee what's
your household income
about 170 okay if you're gonna keep it
develop a plan to pay it and your home
off
within five or six years let's get with
it get it cleaned up if you're if you're
gonna sell it you don't need to recast
your mortgage just throw the debt
through it at the mortgage and then
let's get your mortgage paid off as soon
as possible and then save up and pay
cash for the next rental
because this didn't become a rental buy
plan it was by default
you did not buy this house to be a
rental
you ended up with it being a rental so
is it a good rental i don't know
you can decide that but if you're going
to keep them you got to get them paid
off now
get with it
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more verse
[Music]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today
mataya is with nothing's darcy's up i'm
sorry mata you're up next uh darcy's up
in washington dc hi darcy how are you
hi i am so excited to be speaking to you
guys thank you guys so much for your
help sure what's up
um okay i'll make a long story short
here i am 33 years old i am not married
i have no kids i'm in baby steps four
and six
and my question is what should i do with
an extra two thousand dollars to hit my
fifteen percent retirement goal if i
can't do a backdoor raw due to the pro
rata rule
so you got an aggregation problem you
got too much in the
in the traditional i do i have about 80k
in a traditional ira yeah
okay
uh you can just drop it into a mutual
fund i mean that's all you need to do
the point is just to try to get make
sure you're saving into something uh
what i do in non-retirement mutual fund
investing is i invest in what's called a
low
turnover mutual fund which means they
don't sell the stocks inside the mutual
fund very often
and um
hardly at all like a five percent
turnover ratio would be called a low
turnover mutual fund a good example of
that is just an s p 500 fund uh your
smartvestor pro can hook you up with one
or you can just go buy a smart buy buy a
s p 500 somewhere they're not
non-commissioned
no-brainer
you know you don't there's nothing to it
you just buy it and hold it
because
as the money grows you don't pay taxes
on it
uh like i'm like a rental property you
don't pay taxes on the value increasing
until you sell it
so if you're churning inside that fund
all the time you're always paying taxes
on that sale exactly okay and if they if
they buy and hold the stocks inside the
fund and you hold the fund
then you've got capital gains growth
okay meaning you don't pay taxes on it
until you sell it so what you just
mentioned aggregation i didn't
understand half the words you use what
does that mean what's that mean
okay that's a rule that the irs has that
does not allow a roth ira or backdoor
roth ira if you have a large
as a percentage of your world a large
traditional
uh ira okay so another thing you could
do
you could start to move some of that
traditional over to roth and pay the
taxes on it
that would have the same effect but i
really wouldn't do that until you got
your house paid off i think you're
probably just putting some money in
mutual fund will make it easy enough
matea is with us in eugene oregon
hi matteo how are you
i'm doing good thanks for taking my call
sure what's up
all right so i am uh 18 years old i uh
recently live on my own um
i have
an income but
the majority of that goes to paying all
these financial goals i now have um i am
currently in college and about to
graduate with my associates um
but because of
all the recent events i
i don't have the money to pay for
college and i don't want to just stop
going until i have the money because i'm
so close so i'm kind of hoping for some
guidance
this sounds like you suddenly left home
i did yes why
um i had a very
bad moving situation
with my my parents
at home and i needed to get out
okay i'm sorry yeah are you safe now
i am yes no i i live on my own um no one
knows where i live so it's kind of nice
okay that's not a bad thing
um it is a bad thing that you had to go
through this but i mean it's a good
thing that nobody knows so uh
what do you make
i make um
an average of 1600 a month um between
two jobs um on a good month it can be
like 18 or 1900. what do you do
i am a part-time nanny and part-time
barista
okay
what are you going to school for
um general studies but um focus in
psychology okay
and you're almost through with your
associates
yes i am
okay is have you got the money to finish
that
i do not no um almost as in like i could
it's so it's a long associates because i
started when i was pretty young and i
didn't take a full load of classes um so
i i would say like by fall term i would
be graduated
okay
all right okay rule number one is not
college
rule number one is existence
sustainability
food shelter
clothing
transportation
utilities
in the eighth grade when i was in school
we called that necessities
okay
and so that's the that's the main thing
you have to do right there
until you get that done we don't think
about the other
and if you delay college whoopie dumpty
you're 18 you're safe you've got time
you'll get there
but your big thing is safety
and security meaning that you have a
place to live you have food you have the
lights on
okay because what you're going through
is very scary i mean albeit terrifying
am i wrong
what yeah no you do not know yeah and so
let's just pretend for a second
the way i the way i my my brains work is
if we could get your income from sixteen
hundred to three thousand and you didn't
go to school
i think you could breathe a little
better and then let's start talking
about how we get back to school
okay
does that i mean what if you made four
thousand dollars in a month but you
didn't go to school you'd feel better
than being terrified and going to school
so yeah yeah for sure and we're not
going to do that as a permanent way of
life i believe in education and i want
you to have a a track that you're on to
have a career that's not a barista okay
a long term you don't want to be a 48
year old barista you want to move on you
want to have a career right uh you want
to become
you know whatever it is you want to
become and i want you to get there but i
want to do that from a place of strength
not a strength of not a place of terror
john yeah
can i
can i be real honest with you
yeah what you've done so far is very
brave
and few people have the strength and
bravery to do what you did which is to
keep yourself safe even though it meant
going off on your own
and this is a moment
when people in your situation
bury themselves in short-term decisions
that will haunt you for
years and years and years okay
so hear me say
commit now i will not borrow money i
will no longer be
trapped by anybody and you just escaped
one situation don't jump into another
thing
okay i agree yeah you are 18 about to
finish your associates do you real
you're two years ahead of everybody
okay
so slow down and become safe
become safe you honey are worth more
than sixteen hundred dollars a month
you just are
you work hard you're so far ahead i can
tell you're a hard worker you're brave
you're strong you can do
really hard stuff i want to see you get
a job where you're working full-time and
then going to your associate's degree in
the evenings or in the mornings you can
figure that out i know you can and you
made a you made a big grown-up decision
and you're gonna have to work real hard
okay this is gonna be hard the next
couple of years full-time nanny might
make three to four grand right
um
it depends on the need i i live in a
um i'm just naming for it for a family
i've been with somebody i know i know
you're a babysitter
yeah i want you i want you to change to
a nanny and make three thousand dollars
a month
okay market yourself there in this
double your income yeah this family
probably is your safety lifeline is that
right
um yes yeah they are i actually um have
a boyfriend we're planning to get
married um sometime this summer as well
so
okay
i want you to get somebody that is an
adult that you can
sit down and talk about all your plans
with because right now you're running
and i don't want you to run into a
marriage you're not 100 in on i don't
want you to run into student loans just
to finish i don't want you to run into a
job that's paying you half of what
you're worth right now you're just
running for your life and i want you to
run it or walk to an adult one or two or
three people in your life that you can
sit down and say here's what i'm
thinking and they'll go oh honey slow
down make your school decision
make your career decision
make your marriage decision from
strength
and john and i are saying that
[Music]
your probably
not feeling super strong right now
so any of those three decisions right
now are really really tenuous
i'm not saying you shouldn't get married
not saying you shouldn't finish school
i'm not saying
you know that you're not gonna have a
career but i think you need to get a
financial strength of sustainability and
then go oh from strength i'm gonna
decide to get married not from weakness
this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying 60 000
about two years after that i got a
remote job that pays me a hundred and
thirty thousand dollars all thanks to
what i learned at bethel tech you could
be next get started today at
betheltech.net
and get one thousand to twenty five
hundred dollars off of your tuition
again it's
betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
[Music]
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt-free stage kathleen is with us hey
kathleen how are you hello i'm nervous
that's okay we've never lost a patient
you're gonna make that sounds good
you're gonna make it where do you live i
live in spring texas cool did you grow
up there um no i from up north and then
i went down there i was recruited to
teach oh very good what do you teach um
i'm a school administrator now i've
lived in texas for 33 years okay well
you're a tax on that i'm a texan now
once you've been there 33 years they
they make it official somewhere around
then i think i guess
it's about 30 minutes once you're in
you're oh 30 minutes they jump you in
and you've got the tattoos we know
you're in it all right that's it well
welcome so how much debt did you pay off
i paid off seventy four thousand four
hundred dollars way to go and how long
did this take you 17 months wow
and your range of income during that
time um i make about a hundred thousand
and with my side hustles i made 32 000
so
132. okay cool what's your side hustle
um i started uber eats i did that for a
while and then i got into umpiring with
my
boyfriend so we started umpiring we do
that all the time and then i had kids
that moved back home so i decided that
they could help pay for the mortgage why
not that's a good thing so what are you
umpire
softball softball girl softball what age
um anywhere from six to 16.
so is there anything meaner on the
planet than parents of children playing
organized sports to umpires no sir
no sir
that is because we could solve the
ukraine crisis pretty quickly
that has been a truism since time here
overseas wow if you're behind the plate
you take your mask off at times and just
kind of stare them down
yes
and they look at the floor of the ground
and they're like i'm sorry yeah
no not necessarily
that's right throwing them out i love it
so what's it like what's it like being a
an administrator of a school and then
hopping out of work and then going to do
ubereats do you ever show up to the
house of a student
no i have made sure that i have
delivered in a different area okay all
right yeah that could be that's that's
humbling that'd be weird that's i mean
that's putting it all out there yeah all
right so what kind of debt was the 74
000 um it was
personal loan i had medical loan that i
paid off um i had my ex-husband's
student loan that i still had to pay off
because i co-signed on it which i would
recommend never ever doing
um he passed away but i still paid it
off
um
and just kind of a collage
oh wow so i had about 64 000 but in that
time as i was uber eating and different
things like that i had a car accident
somebody ran into me and drove off so i
had to purchase a new car within that
time
and then also
my youngest got married oh wow so we
cash flowed eleven thousand okay wow
you've already covered a bunch of stuff
yeah
so what inspired you to do all this 17
months ago what was the story what
started you um i met a man um that's
sitting over here and he's always been
my
cheerleader um he's live the dave ramsey
baby steps um forever and
he just kept on encouraging me you know
that this is the way we do it we would
go do things or
go places and we always listen to the
ramsay show and
all the time and he just told me once he
said you know hey send me your finances
you know through email that's set up a
payoff quote and everything you know a
program for you and i was like no i
don't talk about finances i don't want
to talk about finances because i didn't
think it was ever possible even though
you hear all these people say it i just
didn't think it was possible
and i said okay well here's my finances
and i walked out the door and he's like
you don't want to talk about it i'm like
no but um finally he called me that
evening and we talked about it he showed
me how it was possible and how i would
start with the snowball effect and how i
would pay a little bit on one and then i
would pay that off and then i add that
to another one and he had a spreadsheet
all made for me of my income and what i
would pay off and how i could do it and
i mean you were spoon-fed he was just
straight-up i mean he just did it for
you this is awesome yes
17 months later you're free of something
you didn't think was possible correct
wow my paychecks would come in from
ubereats on tuesdays like i would never
take the cash out on it yeah so in
mondays i would take my money from
softball and i would go deposited in the
bank so i would make one payment on
mondays from softball and then i make my
tuesday payments for my ubereats so if i
didn't have softball on the weekend then
i was doing ubereats
i did either ubereats or i did league
ball softball during the week how far
into the 17 months did you go
wait a minute this is going to work
i would say it took about six months
honestly really because i mean i kept on
thinking i got some things paid off but
i don't know the smaller ones i thought
well okay well that was just trusted him
to put the system in place and then you
trusted his
she was a huge cheerleader for me yeah
just a huge motivator and cheerleader
you weren't sure it was going to work in
six months you did it anyway i kept on
doing it i enjoyed what i was doing i'm
being an administrator i'm not in the
classroom anymore so really being out
there on the ball field with the girls
and everything like that i mean that's
true turned in to be a passion for me
just being with them and stuff not the
parents but the girls and
somebody's got to care for those kids
and so that's been really fun just being
out there and doing it so i would say
maybe five to six months but um when i
got the biggest when i got my car paid
off i think that's when i was just like
oh my gosh i got that paid off and that
was the biggest one i remember that was
in january
how long has it been since you were
completely debt free how many years ago
too many like when you started your
working life probably probably probably
had debt your whole adult life yes sir
yeah okay yes sir what kind of freedom
um
did you experience when
you paid off that student loan
because that that that's that's wrapped
up into some other feelings and some
other into loss
there had to have been a cathartic
moment of
goodbye
it was it was pretty unreal and um
it's really weird but the month i did it
was also the month that my youngest got
married
and so um my
ex-mother-in-law was here and you know
and i told her and i mean so it was
really uh rejoicing yeah you know i have
to give her a shout-out she told me she
said
kathy said you know um i told you all
about dave ramsey 30 years ago and you
never listened to me and yada yada
oh what a mother-in-law i told you so i
told you so what an ex-mother-in-law
that's right
but um you know she was there for the
wedding that's all just all that so yeah
it was a big release and it was a big
accomplishment now i just hope my kids
follow in my footsteps and they learned
before i did yeah amen
amen way to go i'm proud of you oh thank
you good work good work very well done
okay now when you back
up and you look at the whole process
what do you tell people the key to
getting out of debt is
having that budget having that budget
and sticking to it and then when you do
your side hustles um really making sure
you're taking that money and you're
putting it towards your debt so you're
putting that towards whatever you're
paying off at the time i think that was
the biggest thing
of just any extra money i had then you
just put it towards that debt
that speeds everything up substantially
very much so
incredible 17 months later she's free
just like that boom
changes everything everything you don't
meet a lot of really great longhorns man
but this guy's done all right he's
decked out dave he's decked out in all
his gear he went to the wrong texas
college but i applaud him he did a good
job
did a good job he's done a wonderful job
now that you're free how's it feel
it feels fantastic and i've saved money
so i've started on you know building up
my next step
and um my financial security um but i've
also taken some of the money to do some
fixes on the house that i needed to do
just kind of making sure that everything
is working order good for you well done
it's been wonderful well done we got a
copy of baby steps millionaires for you
we want that to be the next chapter in
your story go on and be a millionaire
now you're on your way thank you you're
on your way how ordinary people built
extraordinary wealth and how you can too
also a copy of the total money makeover
book
that uh eight million people have now
read you can give that to one of your
kids maybe maybe get the one that just
got married maybe get them moving in the
right direction
so good stuff all right it's kathleen
from spring texas 74 000 paid off in 17
months making 130 with the side hustles
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream
three two one
i'm debt-free
[Music]
[Applause]
i love it
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
dr john deloney ramsey personality is my
co-host today open phones at triple
eight eight two five five two two five
john's new book own your past change
your future is on pre-sale the not so
complicated approach to relationships
mental health and wellness dealing with
all kinds of trauma
getting connected to a community change
your thoughts and actions so here's the
thing john that that we're experiencing
with the sale of the book the book is
selling like hot cakes by the way and if
you want to pre-order the book i'll go
ahead and tell you you can get it for 20
and what comes with it is pretty
incredible
a month of weekly
one-on-one therapy
through our partners at better health
is included
that's unbelievable deal
uh the better health people really
believe in john
and uh as we do but boy they have really
stepped up and made this pre-order
purchase
the bargain of the century right now and
here's why that's important dave that
for years uh the last several years
there's been a shortage people they get
the courage up to say hey i want to go
get a go get an appointment with a local
counselor
with a local therapist and
can't get in you get put on a six month
wait list and we just we're talking
about an article that came out today
talking about the wait list across the
country
and
the better help their
guarantee is they'll someone will call
you within 24 hours and so my fear was
someone's gonna close this book and say
all right it's time and i got some stuff
i got to deal with not everyone who
reads is gonna need therapy but there's
time
and then guaranteed if you read this
book you'll be in there that's right but
uh they're gonna pick it up and then go
cool in eight months i'll uh i'll get
back on that so man that better help
deal with what it does it does wake you
up and go there's a there's a chance
that i don't have to live
with them with with the mental issues
i'm dealing with that's right i can i
can get the i can get past things i need
some help starting today i need some
help and this better help thing helps
you get it incredible yeah yeah i love
it really grateful for them
the the the whole premise of the book
and um
is just to change the story yeah the
story the the stories of our life as you
wrote
um good and bad
are how we operate in our brains
and uh you can be set free from some of
the bad stories that keep running
they're on their own loop in our brains
aren't they they're on automatic
response over and over and over yeah and
you can just even just even realizing
that's what's happening
and it doesn't have to be this way and
then you can
the challenge there is now what do i do
and that's what we walk through yeah own
your past it's there we're not going to
deny it it happened
change your future you don't have to be
what happened to you hey and i found out
today uh i don't even know this is going
out today but they
down they uploaded uh so if you go to my
normal podcast the dr john dolone's show
they released today as a special release
the first chapter of the audiobook as a
bonus yeah so you can go check out if
you want to if you're interested i'm
thinking about i don't know the first
chapter of the of the audiobook's been
released today on with the podcast and
so you can go check it out
as read by the author
oh yeah you know and this is the first
audio book that i wrote the forward and
i actually voiced the forward oh yeah it
was strange that i don't know who voiced
the forwards and the other ones i wrote
but it's only one i've ever voiced
probably kelly she did it no one even
knows yeah well nobody reads it forward
that's why nobody cares
but uh all it all i said was it's a
great book you should read it or
something like that so
uh dash forward you know so own your
past change your future by dr john
deloney the latest or the newest or the
soonest the next number one best seller
it's not yet because it's not out yet
technically but it is on pre-sale you
can get it at ramseysolutions.com
and get yourself signed up and uh man
you get a lot of so you get the e-book
and the audio book all as part of the
package along with a month of
free one-on-one weekly therapy through
our partners at better help
dave is with us in indianapolis hi dave
welcome to the ramsey show
hi thanks for taking my call sure what's
up hey i just had a few quick questions
so
i've been saving for a home for what
seems like a very long time
i'm 33 years old i was just recently
married last year
my wife is 27
and i have a 13 year old son
we just purchased a house this year i
paid it off
um and i have zero debt
and uh i was just wondering uh what what
would your next step be i i need a plan
and a path for my
future okay so you're 100 debt free
yes and your household income is what
uh 46 okay very well done wow man very
well done
okay there's only three things you can
do with money you can invest it to
create more money
you can give it in generosity
and you can enjoy it
you should always do all three
and you can decide the percentages
because you have done an incredible job
and have set yourself up to win but i
would not recommend giving all of your
income away but i would always give some
of it i would not recommend investing
all of your income but i would always
invest some of it and i would not
recommend consuming or enjoying all of
your income but i would consume and
enjoy some of it
so what are you going to do with it yeah
well i did purchase a house it's not my
dream home it needs a lot of fixing um
someone you're living in
yes okay
oh so you got so you're gonna have to
spend some money on the house
yes how much
i have no idea probably
at least 10 and 15 000. okay we'll just
put that in your budget man
that's your new that's one of your new
payments you pay yourself for the
renovation
okay i just paid it off last week so uh
that's kind of what i was thinking but
uh yeah congratulations absolutely and
and you're that's that's part of your
enjoyment money and then part of your
money is investing
and part of your money is generosity and
just keep on man you're doing a great
job
very well done
wow yeah and
man i i've heard this call more often
than i would have thought where someone
crossed as a major milestone and they
kind of have this moment of feeling
untethered um i'm i just let the ski
rope go and i'm kind of all over the
place
just get a new plan
just just be intentional about what
comes next right whether it's saving for
your house retirement give a chunk of
money away go do something fun go on
vacation you paid your house off man
celebrate um don't let this paralyze you
yeah here's the thing if you will write
it down that this much is going to this
this much is going a this much going to
be this much you're going to see
whatever it is
the simple written out formula that's
what we do with our money all right i
just opened my mail before i came down
here while i go i got i got a check from
the uh publisher from an old book years
ago but it's a nice little check still
selling
and uh i know i know exactly where
that's gonna go i did not know that that
check was coming and i did not know
exactly how much it would be if i had
known it was coming because we don't
know until we get the statement in on
the royalties right but i do know
exactly what percentage of it is going
to generosity i know what percentage of
it is going to enjoyment and i know what
percentage of it is going to further
investing and because it's all preset on
every dollar that comes into the
ramsey's household these days and so um
and then that and then within each of
those categories here's how generosity
looks we do that through the foundation
in our case um and we tithe we're
christians so we give a tenth of our
income to our local church and here's
how the investing looks i'm gonna buy
real estate i'm gonna pay mutual funds i
got this next project i'm working on
over here i'm building up for and over
here some enjoyment here's something
sharon wants to do and something we want
to buy at the house or do something and
you know go on a trip or whatever and so
it's all laid out it's all laid out it's
kind of boring
[Laughter]
but it's all very very very intentional
no one wins by accident right and then
says look i won how did that happen they
all go it was a series of progressive
incremental decisions intentional
decisions that cause you to win that's
right it's what winning always looks
like in mental health and marriage and
parenting in business and money
if we could convince the world that the
path forward
is boredom and consistency it's doing it
over and over again
we'd win systems systems let's create a
good system you know and just keep going
one of our buddies wrote a book that's
been on the number one on and off number
one and on and off it's been hanging out
on the best sellers for about a year
atomic habits well it's a couple years
old now yeah that's james that's clear
and that's all he talks about he says
you know people don't win because they
set goals they win because they
systematically work incremental progress
in atomic habits small habits a series
of small habits a series of small habits
and a constant process to take you
towards your goal and you rise and fall
to the level of your system yep right
and so you can have all the goals in the
world but if your house is full of
twinkies you don't have a gym gym
equipment you know it's going to be
tough for you you can lift twinkies
into the mouth
over and over but yeah it's about your
systems man set yourself up for success
keep in mind those twinkies will last
500 years
which is exciting and out of your stuff
which is exactly why you should not
ingest this
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
[Music]
hey it's john deloni co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions it's the ramsey show where
debt is dumb cash is king and the paid
off home mortgage has taken the place of
the bmw as the status symbol of choice
i'm dave ramsey your host dr john
deloney ramsey personality is my co-host
today as we answer your questions about
your life and your money your
relationships your mental health your
jobs and your careers this is the ramsay
show we're glad you're here open phones
at triple eight eight two five five two
two five chad is in minneapolis hi chad
welcome to the ramsay show
thanks for having me on sure what's up
so um i'm in um kind of step five slash
upgrade to six uh quick backstory i've
got a hundred and thirty thousand dollar
paid for home uh with a hundred grand
grand in the bank and we'll be looking
to upgrade here recently or in the
future
i think i might have the question but
my bait my salary was about 110 and then
through some restructuring negotiation
within my organization i
got up to 120 salary with a
i got a 30 000 bonus and a 12 000 car
allowance so that brings me up to about
160. um there's not any income
restrictions on having a designated roth
401k through my employer is it or is
that no iras no income restrictions only
on iras
okay
um
the old and then
and that so that's what sort of solved
that one my one question there is uh
because i'm i'm going to be looking to
upgrade my house you're single right
i i'm i'm i am
engaged um so we've got we've got six
kids together so it's a very busy
household um so we need we need a little
more room to grow
you got six kids and you've been too
busy to get married
uh no so uh i have i have four children
from a previous marriage
together you're just trying to just
still feeling it out a little bit to see
if this is the one yeah okay yeah yeah
jeez
yeah
um
but but i'm gonna be i'm gonna be
receiving a a check
from
i never took care of it through the
divorce uh of about 28 thousand dollars
through a qdro uh from my ex's pension
um does it make sense to
that you can roll that you can just roll
to an ira
right but does it is it is it very anti
ramsay
to
pay to pay the penalties get that in
cash so i can have a larger down payment
on a bigger
house
it doesn't really matter if it's
anti-ramsay
it just you're going to give the
government a whole big pile of money
that i wouldn't do
i mean it's not well you've got a ramsey
thing it's you know you're gonna you're
gonna give the government 30 30
you're borrowing extra down payment
money at 30 interest
right
no but i wouldn't give the government 30
of my money earned that money i would
have been i would have paid that same
yeah but i mean i have a pile of money i
have the opportunity to borrow money at
30 interest to put more on my down
payment on my house i think i'll pass
and you didn't earn it yeah
like
if i got hit by a meteor i'd probably do
things differently today but i didn't
right so you didn't earn the money and
so i yeah i wouldn't would you take out
a um an additional small loan at 30
percent to down put down payment on your
house
no yeah same thing same thing man
same math
so yeah just roll it to a traditional
max out your roth a 401k over at work or
up to 15 and then save like a crazy
person and finish up your down payment
get it get the down payment as big as
you can get it you're heading in the
right direction so i know it feels like
you had a pile of money coming and it's
gonna feel so good it's not it's just
not no it's you're gonna give a pile of
money to the government if you do that
and we don't we don't give money to the
government it's not a ramsey thing
though it's just a it's just a math
thing
you know it's you know it's not you
stole that principle from math dave
[Laughter]
you're full of one-liners on this
particular call i'm just saying
cubana is with us in baton rouge hey
cubana what's up
hi ramsay can you hear me absolutely how
can we help
okay so
my husband and i we open up a company
back in may of 2021
and i wanted to know how can i make sure
that our personal and business finances
is ready for the tax season
okay
uh back in may of 2021 i would have
started this if you haven't you're gonna
have to go back and do it starting now
does the company have a separate
checking account that you only do
business out of
yes it does okay if you only put
business money or income into that
account and you only paid business
expenses out of that account and you
didn't do it anywhere else that account
the income and outgoing that account
will show what your business has done
because it shows your revenue and it
shows your expenses and what's left is
called profit
um it does but
honestly i never really looked at it
because i didn't know what to look for
and i recently started looking at it
when i found um
i saw you on youtube i think or maybe it
was an influence on instagram not sure
but i started looking and i was getting
a little insecure about the members
because i know we have an audit coming
up and made for the company um what is
it called workers cost
a worker's comp audit that's agency
yeah yeah i wouldn't be i wouldn't be
freaked out about it jump online at
click on
elp it stands for endorsed local
provider find a tax person there in
baton rouge that we endorse they
probably also do small business
bookkeeping and you'll be able to pay
them a fee to untangle your barrel of
fish hooks
so basically you got like three ski
ropes all wrapped together and twisted
up and that's all of your numbers but
they're all there they're all in the
barrel we just got to get them out and
untangle them and show your proper
income your proper expenses and your
proper profit
and um that'll also help you get your
taxes ready for 2022 and it'll set you
up perfectly for your workers comp audit
so you can know what to pay properly on
the workers comp it should if you have
all your expenses in there in that
account or anywhere where you can get
your hands on them then you can you can
go back and develop a profit loss
statement for the six months of 2021 and
that's really what needs to happen and a
bookkeeper can help you do that this is
it's really sixth grade math and
organization
is all it is it's not a it's not a super
difficult
uh intellectual exercise anybody can do
it uh it's just a matter you've got to
get all the expenses
for each month categorize them by
category all the income for each month
categorize it by category the difference
in the two is your profit
and uh if you do that six times for six
months you have your you have your your
income statement or your profit loss
statement for the year 2021 since you
opened in june around june 1st of 2021
and you'll be there uh but if you need
some help you can pay somebody a few
hundred dollars if it's the company's
making money to do it for you
i personally can't stand to do that kind
of stuff it drives me nuts so it's one
of the first things i'd pay somebody
else to do
but uh but i know how to do it i just
don't want to do it
and just lazy in that way i don't know
it's just
it's a it's
yeah yeah but if you want if you want to
do it we have people that we can hook
you up to do that right that's how it
works this is the ramsey show
[Music]
if you're not using puretalk for your
wireless you're paying too much puretalk
gives you the same great 5g coverage on
the same 5g network as one of the big
guys for half the cost the average
family saves over 800 a year go to
puretalk.com and choose the affordable
plan that's right for you with their
30-day risk-free guarantee you have
nothing to lose go to puretalk.com and
enter the promo code ramsey to save 50
off your first month
[Music]
[Music]
seems like january 1st is two years ago
how your resolution's going
you're like most people you hit it hard
in january and by valentine's day they
were done
well you can reach all of your money
goals this year but it takes
accountability
it takes intentionality it takes a plan
to get them done and you get all of this
by joining a financial peace university
class
you'll go through our proven money plan
with other people who will help you stay
motivated they'll hold you accountable
they'll encourage you because they're
trying to get out of debt and build
wealth just like you are financial peace
university classes are both in person
and they're online there's no excuse not
to give this a try
you can get back on track with your
money goals almost 10 million people
have been through this class and have
had successful results not only getting
out of debt but many of them have gone
on to become baby steps millionaires
following the baby steps that's where we
wrote the number one bestselling book
from
so get started for free
a free trial for financial peace
university
at ramsey solutions dot com slash fpu
that's ramsey solutions dot com slash
fpu
adam is with us in atlanta hi adam
welcome to the ramsay show
hi guys thank you for having me sure
what's up
so i'm uh i've made some pretty pretty
dumb mistakes and i'm uh i'm pretty
terrified of making some more so i was
hoping i could get some advice on
i guess how i can move forward with
getting a house
i've got some car debt from some pretty
stupid mistakes
been there done that trying to get rid
of it now
i've got about twenty thousand dollars
in savings
that i could either use to dump into the
car debt and try and get rid of as fast
as possible
or do i try and keep building off of
that to get enough for a down payment
for the house cool
i did that's a good question it's a
valid question how old are you
i am 29. okay and you're fairly new to
this whole ramsay stuff right
um
i've been around it a lot but pretty
much ignored it most of my life but uh
that means you're new to it right now
i'm trying to
try to get
that's okay that's okay it's all good
and um what do you make of your
i'm right around 105 000 a year good for
you and you're single
i am okay what do you owe on the car
uh right around 38 000. okay is that
your only debt
um
i kicked my student loans to the curb uh
last month they are gone now way to go
yeah the car is it the car is it all
right well there's two ways to go at
this okay
the fast way to get a house
is dump the car
and get you cheap get you a cheap car
and pay cash for it
the slow way to get a house is get the
car paid off and then save up your down
payment
i tell people and
and there's a reason for this i don't
just it's not just because
i don't want people here's the thing i
want you on a house i grew up in the
real estate business i love real estate
i think owning real estate is an
essential part of building wealth long
term so i do want you to get a house i
just don't want the house to get you and
when you have a 38 thousand dollar car
debt uh you don't need a house till you
get that mess cleaned up okay because
it's gonna bite you in the butt
uh so i want you to have here's the
thing you move into a house with a car
debt and no money and you put all your
money down on the house as soon as you
do something's gonna break on the house
the roof's gonna leak
yep just murphy's law okay but if you
move into a house with no car debt and
an emergency fund of three to six months
of expenses and put your down payment
down and you got so you got money in the
bank no debt when you move in nothing
will happen to this house it'll be
perfect you'll love it
that's how life works man what kind of
car is it
uh it's a the late model key it's a
couple years old
what could you get for it right now
probably more than i paid for it
probably more than 38.
i could probably get around 45 according
to kelly blue look brother sell it
yesterday
do you love this car has it wormed its
way into your heart
um i do like it but i don't know if i
like it that much yeah so here's the
thing yeah i'd sell it what i just told
you was the best way the only way i
would tell you to buy a house and i do
want you to buy a house
is when you have no debt and have an
emergency fund plus your down payment
okay
so the two ways to get there are quickly
dump the car buy seven thousand dollar
car for cash you have no debt build your
emergency fund then build your down
payment then buy you a house that's
going to happen very quick you'll have a
house by christmas
or
pay this car off
keep it
build your emergency fund
build your down payment and you'll have
a house by
the next christmas
or the one after that either one's okay
there's nothing dumb here because the
car is not completely out of control
given your income it's getting close but
it's not completely out of control the
if you want to know what out of control
is you don't own things with wheels and
motors all totaled up to be equal more
than half your annual income
and you're not there fair enough unless
you got other things with wheels or
motors that we don't know about sir but
if this is the only one you got it's
below half your annual income so it's
keeper it's okay but you need to get it
paid off for you by a house or the stars
have aligned and you can get rid of this
thing you can have seven thousand bucks
you can walk over to the lot and buy a
beater
and seven thousand
right a sustainable car yeah and man now
you're talking you're debt-free you got
20 grand in the bank you are well on
your way now you can buy george
campbell's honda for less than seven
thousand you could buy that for about a
dollar forty five have you seen that
thing
he starts it with a rope out in the
parking lot dude
it's ridiculous
a rope i tried to spin
i drive bad cars and that car makes me
go come on man
george is truly not a car guy i've been
giving him a hard time on the air about
his car so yeah you can go either way
adam uh personally i like cars i'm a car
guy
uh but i like houses more
because they go up in value uh and until
recently cars have never gone up in
value and they won't long term but
recently they have been
uh so i i personally would dump a stupid
thing while the getting's good and get
me a house
and then move up in car with cash later
after i get my house
but it's not a big deal either way
you're you're not in the dumb column
either direction
i compared that with what you and i have
done before
you're nowhere near us adam yeah yeah
you you got us both of us beat i mean in
in you're a lot smarter than we were so
all right nathan's in birmingham hey
nathan what's up
hey dave a quick question for you about
long-term disability
i just switched jobs got a new job and
uh looking at uh purchasing it
question is do i go through my employer
or do i go kind of the the personal
route
and get my own long-term disability and
keep it with me
uh you know if i were to switch jobs in
the future etc yeah you can go you can
get it most anywhere i would get it
through your employer just because
you're going to find it to be about
probably 25 probably 75 cheaper
than in the open market a group policy
on on long-term disability is just it's
one of the best buys out there it's very
inexpensive i'll tell you how
inexpensive it is it's the only kind of
insurance at ramsey that i pay a hundred
percent of as the employer
we furnish it as a benefit it just
doesn't cost me much to give it to
everybody
nothing like health insurance for sure
and so um
you know we pay almost all the health
insurance but not all of it we want
everybody to have a little skin the game
on that but this stuff just doesn't cost
much but if you go buy it as an
individual policy i bet you're going to
find it's 4x
okay
i maybe it may be 3x but i mean
somewhere in there it's a lot more so
buy through your employer and here's the
other thing if you will buy it with
after tax dollars
after your check has gotten the taxes
out of it not before tax dollars that's
what i would do because
then if you become disabled your
disability income is not taxable oh
that's a good one i didn't know that if
you buy it with pre-tax dollars your
disability income is taxable
and uh it's a big difference big
difference i had no idea they would tax
your
disability and confidence man they will
take it all they tax everything man
tax everything so uh yeah
but still especially if you're in
uh this cost uh issue will be better
especially if you're in some kind of an
industry where
um
you you you know you're not just driving
a if you're driving if you're just
driving a desk that's you know you it's
just white-collared
cat the category of work you do dictates
the cost of long-term disability more
than your age or health what about those
little 12 a month dollar month to buy
the three three months oh that's awful
is it bad awful yeah stay away from that
stuff yeah that's just gimmick stuff you
need an emergency fund to cover that job
so that that's all you need cover that
you have self-insured through that it's
the long-term disability that's a
problem this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
chaos
that's what it can feel like when your
business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jump start your cfo career
[Music]
dr john dolone ramsey personality is my
co-host today
in the lobby of ramsey solutions on the
debt free stage debbie austin kate and
allison are with us hey guys how are you
we're great dave welcome where do you
live we live in northwest indiana just
um outside of chicago illinois okay cool
welcome to nashville thank you and all
the way here to do a debt-free screen
yes very fun how much did you pay off
168 000
in 12 years
but our
journey actually started on n09
or actually no 07
when we paid off 40 thousand dollars in
two years
and that was credit cards
student loans all the stupid things that
my husband and i did
so
when you put the two together that's
our total okay all right and yeah okay i
got you and your house range of
household income i don't know through
the 12 years maybe yes uh we started at
100 and um just doubled okay all right
what do you do for a living
i work at a church um i'm a children's
ministry director
very good and what was the 168 000
um the mortgage
oh look at the she's rolling out the
spreadsheet
[Music]
covered the whole refrigerator yes it
did wow i love it
that is a spreadsheet of all
spreadsheets so that's the 12 years of
marking it out yeah okay so 09 you guys
run into us i guess you know seven we
ran into you and then two years later we
paid off the house at the house and then
12 years more the house is paid off
correct very good what's the house worth
um
i believe the house is worth 350
000 now cool cool and how much you have
in investments
um
well
my husband recently passed away oh my
god
um five months ago oh my so that's the
part of the story then a big part of
this this is a big part of our story
okay well tell me the whole thing let me
back up yeah i'll let you start you tell
the story okay
um
so
ryan my husband uh loved to spend money
and so
his mentality was just to charge it and
so
when we found u107 he was a deacon at
our church
and they asked him they asked him to
find something
to get us to help people in our church
to do our finances and he came across
your program and he listened to it in
two days and he came home and he said
honey we're cred we're cutting up our
credit cards and we're going to get out
of debt and you're like who are you and
what have you done with my husband i was
because it was something that i always
wanted
but um just wasn't able to get um both
of us on board at the same time
so we went through it we he delivered
pizzas i watched 10 kids in my home
the kids picked up cans in the ditches
like everything we paid to show towards
that forty thousand dollars went off um
to the forty thousand dollars so then
after that um we kind of slowed our
lives down because we were we had three
kids and we were really busy and during
that time ryan found the job that he was
currently at milwaukee valve and so he
was working more and had a goal in mind
and wanted to get to that goal and so we
kind of slowed things down and so then
over the over the 12 years
we
put
we
colored off our lines as much as we
could we did cash flow christian
education my kids went to christian
school
austin just will be graduating in may
with a degree in business and cash
flowed his um first or his four years of
college allison or allison's in high
school and kate is a freshman at florida
gulf coast university studying marine
science
so um with all of that uh we cash flowed
three hundred thousand dollars in
tuition wow so um so what happened what
kind of illness did he have um he had a
blood clot to the heart
so no warning no it was a complete and
utter shock he
passed on september 22nd oh my gosh and
how old was he 46. oh lord yes oh my
gosh so i am
my family and i are
i would be in a completely different
situation today had dave ramsey not
crossed my husband's path
15 years ago because i know that i would
not be financially secure where i am
today i know i would be selling my home
i'd be getting a full-time job wow and i
don't yeah because
he had had everything in place and i am
completely taken care of what a good man
he was the best oh my gosh so
um
yeah god is good he is providing for us
he has
been amazing um i just can't speak
enough about our lord yeah and uh but
the suddenness of this
tragedy it's that that's what gets you
yes i mean it always gets you but the
suddenness of this and as young as he
was
amazing and he was a great dad and great
husband to boot oh my gosh
his dream was to come here when we saw
paid off the house and so
we're
that uh picture i just saw in the corner
over there that is a car that is a truck
i drove um it was a 2002 uh yukon excel
and uh she sees the truck we see the
husband look at that
there's a truck
for those of you watching on youtube you
saw the photo the real heartache in that
photo was that truck right
he always uh said honey that truck's
gonna make us rich one day
oh that's a good line hey just just so
you know debbie he's here with you yes
he's here he is he's here with all of us
absolutely it's awesome yeah and
austin's got the headset on the second
headset so austin you were in college
when all this was going on right yeah so
he was sick for about two weeks
and uh
i mean me and him would talk on the
phone every day
for like 40 minutes every day and uh
for two weeks he just wouldn't pick up
his phone
and it was pretty hard but then
the day before he passed he felt better
and we talked on the phone
and
i was like
starting to apply for jobs and stuff
like that and he just said he was proud
and then
the next day he was gone those are the
three most important words the father
can say to his son as i'm proud of you
i'm so glad you got to hear that man
what a gift
he said that to his kids a lot oh gosh
what a great man
what a great man it looks to me like he
had good reason to be proud absolutely
yeah absolutely you guys are studs
you're amazing thank you very cool well
paying off the house and all that stuff
really doesn't matter
um in the light of all of this except
that it gives you a a a comfortable
uh
safe place to grieve this extreme loss
i mean god if you had payments and stuff
coming out your ears and everything else
should be a whole different world for
you yes and so it's a horrible thing
that you guys have gone through but um
but the best of the best possible way to
go through a horrible thing
you know i guess is the only way i know
how to say it there's nothing cooler
than you know people say the words i
love you a lot i'm proud of you a lot
and right now y'all are living
what love looks like what love
love with feet and hands on it right
which is a plan um that he worked that
in the middle of the night probably i
was sleeping to make sure the thing look
at that spreadsheet
yeah there's that one that's
unbelievable
that just beautiful man i love this guy
i was in the office next to he had it on
the wall get up leave the cave kill
something drag it home
with the mortgage principal right next
to it i love this guy he was a huge huge
dave ramsey fan he was a huge fan of his
uh your podcast every day
it didn't matter
where we were
it was always on
what a legacy
talk about change your family tree man
yes he did wow yes he did thank you guys
for coming to share and it's a painful
thing for you to have to share
um but uh what a wonderful way to honor
the work your whole family has done but
certainly the uh
the leadership that he brought to your
family on this subject is pretty
incredible and set you guys up to win so
thank you for sharing that
oh i think my allergies are acting up
john yeah
there's dust in here man there's dust in
here i'm not crying you're crying
that's right
oh you guys are awesome thank you so
much you're we're so proud of you thank
you very well done well we've got a copy
of baby steps millionaires for you uh if
you're not already you will be you've
got the uh the table set and uh the next
chapter uh it wasn't the way you wrote
the book wasn't the way you were gonna
write it but uh the next chapter is here
and uh you guys are all set up to go on
and move to what god's got for you next
yeah pretty incredible count it down
let's hear a great debt free scream
three two one
[Music]
[Applause]
unbelievable
wow
[Music]
oh
man
[Applause]
wow
this is the ramsay shot
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
our scripture of the day psalm 145 18
the lord is near to all who call on him
to all who call on him in truth
winston churchill said truth is in
contro
incontrovertible
panic may resent it ignorance may deride
it
malice may distort it but there it is i
have never heard that quote from him i
haven't either i love it fabulous i love
it fabulous quote
all right we went out and we gotta take
a minute after that met with debbie and
the kids after during the commercial
break almost didn't make it back in
uh because the hugs and oh my gosh
what a um
poignant thing
oh my gosh
how often i've heard that question asked
um when somebody actually sets
everything up to take care of their
their family i i hear that question with
some regularity over the years
it's almost as if they knew yeah well we
do know that's right i love your answer
so her in-laws asked her because her
husband had everything set up the wills
and everything was set up
uh so what happened her in-law said did
he know he was going to pass and we're
like yeah we all know we're going to
pass yes that's why we do this we can
choose family or we put our we get our
act together oh my goodness gracious
beautiful
so um what three incredible young young
men and women their kids their kids wow
what a great what a great oh
legacy all right alan is in chicago hey
allen welcome to the ramsay show
hey dave how are you better than i
deserve how can we help
i got a career question for you i'm a
driver trainer for a small mom and
popcorn trucking company
make about 93 000 a year i got an offer
at a bigger more corporate trucking
company
and
the new job would be about six dollars
more an hour but they're not guaranteed
over time in the job i'm at now i'm
guaranteed 20 to 25 some working months
translate all of that into annual income
what are you going to make at the new
place annually and what did you make at
the at the current place annually
93 annually at the current place the new
place
do not guarantee me over time there's
some available i know what do you think
you'll make
how about 70.
why would you go down
well it'd be
15 hours less a week
so i'd have more home time i guess how
many hours are you working
65 now
okay will mom and papa let you a mom and
pop operation let you adjust down
could uh yes probably would i i like the
income though that's one thing i'd like
the income i don't mind the babysit
seven no kids anything that nature so
the hours aren't really bothering me i
guess the hours aren't bothering you
make more money why would you take less
hours and work less then
because i figured the bigger the bigger
company the corporate company would have
probably more um
uh future opportunities i guess
they have to be a lot because you're
taking a 30 pay cut
and there's something about there's
something about going from
a small organization where you're kind
of the big dog you're a leader
to man you will be a expendable number
at a big giant corporation
yeah that's kind of guess where i want
your guys advice on to that i think that
the new job obviously would have more an
hour but less hours they weren't
guaranteed
the overtime there yeah but you're gonna
make less money
and you told me money was important to
you and ours didn't bother you
true true
why would you go make less money and
work for a big company no if you're a
burned-out
father with a couple of young kids and
you're like man i'm working 90 hours a
week i miss my family i got this other
off-ramp well then that's a different
discussion but
i wouldn't want you to describe yeah i'd
stay where you are man jennifer's in new
york city hi jennifer welcome to the
ramsey show
hi thank you what's up
so i was calling for some advice
um my mom's cousin just passed a month
ago and they had nothing planned no well
you know advanced directive
so
my brother and i
um are trying to teach this as a
learning experience and
i did print out well how um advanced
directive and i'm planning on
speaking to her
um about it
and i just want to see where i should
and the advice where to go from here she
also is a hoarder
and
i have my own family
and
my own
um i'm very busy so i'm just trying to
navigate so what is your question
what do you want
how can we help just
just some advice of how to speak to her
about this next chapter of her life and
what advice you'd have for speaking to
her about
what to do with all of her stuff and um
basically yeah
and
in terms of what to do in terms of her
getting a will done
yeah
yeah okay
trying to get her to put something on
paper or something concrete so
we don't have another nightmare yeah
well
that's the way i would approach it it's
mom it would be a gift to me
and to my brother
if you had a will even if you leave it
all to someone else i don't need the
money but if you would just make it make
it easier to deal with upon your death
what you want done by having a will it
would be a gift to us
and if you want some help getting all
that done jennifer just go to
mamabearlegalforms.com
mamabearlegalforms.com
and you can get a downloadable will very
inexpensively and she can you can you
can help her for 30 minutes to an hour
she can get it all filled out and she'd
have a will um but yeah you know but
then she has the right to
you know if you make it easy for her to
do by coaching her holding her hand and
getting her to sign it not but not
because she thinks you want her money or
you want her dead or something weird
like that but just because
you want her to you want to be able to
make sure her wishes are fulfilled and
you're asking her to give you the gift
of
clarity and legal clarity
yeah okay and yeah that sounds good it
sounds like your mom has struggled with
she's got does she have mental health
challenges she's a hoarder she's got
stuff going on in her mind okay yeah so
yeah
have some space in your in in reality
have some space in your heart that this
conversation may not go well
that she may accuse you of all kind of
things get mad at you and not want to
think about her own death or letting go
of her stuff
and
know that that's stuff that she's
struggling with that's not on you okay
you're the responsible thing is to have
this hard conversation with dignity and
respect
but if it doesn't go well it doesn't go
well you know what i mean and it's not
worth going to war with um a a mom who's
not well
but it is worth having that conversation
you know you ask
and you hold
the subject lightly don't let your
relationship with her hinge on whether
she does this or not
okay and maybe tell her that you
hopefully you are
um you and your home y'all are getting
your wheels all taken care of and your
brother's getting his all taken care of
this is just hey the family learned a
hard lesson with your husband passing
and we're gonna make sure this doesn't
happen we've got it all set up and we'd
love to have this conversation with you
yeah that's that's a big deal
and the big thing is this it's very hard
for any parent to take instruction
regardless of their age from their
children
yeah we call it the powdered butt
syndrome once someone has powdered your
butt they don't want your opinion on sex
or money
okay and so it's it's hard it doesn't
even even though she you may be you
might be an estate planning attorney it
doesn't matter and uh
and she might have uh never graduated
kindergarten but it doesn't matter she's
still your mother and she still thinks
she knows better than you that's just
how parenting works so so this is not
something she you're gonna go tell her
you need two that's not how you do this
no no no
here's how you can love and help me if
you please give me the gift of that use
the word gift
it would be a gift to me
just like if your husband had had all
this done it would have been a gift to
you and us we wouldn't have been working
through all this in the
barrel of fish hooks right now we would
have instead been um
you know we would have been just
grieving his passing and still we've got
to work through all these legal
challenges and ownership challenges
because he didn't have this done and so
it's reminding me i'm doing it for my
family brother's doing it for his family
and it would be a gift to us if you
would do it to help us with you even and
mom we don't want your money it's not
it's not about money money you do
whatever you want to do with your money
it's your money it's your money we're
not here to try to get your money that's
not that's not the agenda or your stuff
we want to honor your wishes the best we
can yeah we want to we want you to have
your will
upon your death
told to us and it's called a will
that's why they call it that
so um it is absolutely vital
john deloney good show thank you sir
good show to the folks in the booth
great work back there
i'm dave ramsey we'll be back with you
before you know it in the meantime
remember there's ultimately only one way
to financial peace and that's to walk
daily with the prince of peace
christ jesus
[Music]
hey it's john deloney co-host of the
ramsay show did you know over 18 million
people listen to the ramsay show every
week a lot of those people listen on one
of our 600 plus radio stations across
the country to find a station near you
go to ramseysolutions.com
[Music]
you